- Hey everyone, this is Jeremy
Schifeling with Khan Academy.
Super excited to be
joining you this evening
for our session on "Getting
started with Remote Learning".
And just to sort of set
the tone for the evening,
we know that there's some
challenging times out there.
And we're all struggling to figure out
as parents and educators,
what can we do to serve our students
and our children the best way possible.
And so with that in mind,
I just wanna give you a sense of
who's gonna be sharing their
stories with you tonight,
and then what you can do next.
So joined on the line is Meaghan Pattani,
who is Khan Academy's Lead Educator,
training teachers all around the country.
As you can see,
she was an amazing high
school biology teacher,
high school track and field coach.
Then you also have myself,
former kindergarten teacher,
mostly known for teacher ties
and making smoothies for his kids.
And that being said,
I wanna give you a chance
to introduce yourselves.
So I wanna start with a
couple of quick questions.
These are pretty important
'cause I'm gonna use these,
that can inform the
live demonstration we do
in the next few minutes.
So go ahead and answer this question.
What grade level do you teach?
Are they from elementary
to high or even beyond?
I'll be curious to find out.
Again, we'll use that
to really personalize
the kind of experiences
you see on the screen in a few minutes.
Okay, we're gonna close
this poll in a few minutes,
three, two, one, we'll
share those results.
And it looks like we've got
a big chunk of high school teachers here
as well as some elementary and middle.
So that's fantastic.
Thanks for joining.
I'm gonna ask you one
other question as well,
which is, regardless of school level,
what subject do you teach?
Everything from math,
to ELA, let's know more.
Thanks so much for participating,
go ahead and close this
poll, share the results.
Sure enough,
it looks like we've got a
plurality of math teachers,
but also some folks
from across disciplines,
so thanks again for joining.
Okay, so that being said,
I wanna answer a couple of sort of
ground rules for this webinar.
For those who are curious,
you will absolutely get a
recording of this afterwards
that you can share with anyone you like,
fellow educators,
administrators, even parents.
And then absolutely,
please use the Questions
feature at any point.
Meaghan gonna respond to your questions
right now as you type them in.
And then we're gonna take
some questions live as well.
So please let us know what's on your mind,
and we'll respond in real time.
Okay that being said,
the three big questions
that we're gonna address
this evening, are as follows.
Number one, why do you
even wanna use Khan Academy
for remote learning in the first place?
We'll dive a little bit into
the underpinnings of our site.
Number two, how can you use Khan Academy
to make remote learning
as effective as possible?
We know you've got this big
challenge in front of you,
we wanna give you all
the tools and resources
to be as successful as you can.
And third, and finally,
what else is on your mind?
How can we help, as you
sort of face this next step
in preparing your students for success.
So that being said, I wanna start
with this beginning question
of why use Khan Academy
for remote learning?
And the reason I've chosen
these images on this screen,
which take you back to the very
early days of Khan Academy,
as Sal Khan himself was
building it out a decade ago,
is that, even though we often associate
Khan Academy with the classroom today,
at its very beginning,
everything on Khan Academy was remote.
Sal was sitting in his
closet, as you can see,
creating the videos, creating the content,
it became the first
lessons on Khan Academy.
And the result is,
because that's always
been part of our DNA,
even as we move into the classroom,
you can be sure of two things.
Number one, Khan Academy is for learners
who are learning anytime.
You don't have to be working
at the same time as students,
they can respond to the specific skills
you want them to practice.
They get instant feedback
as soon as they do,
and you always keep tabs on
how your students are doing.
And then number two, no
matter where you are,
no matter where your learners are,
Khan Academy can bring you together.
Students don't even need a computer,
they can now access Khan
Academy on smartphones
using our app or the mobile website.
And in addition,
our content is available
in over 40 languages.
And as a nonprofit,
it's all free for you, all
free for your students.
So that's why Khan Academy
is sort of uniquely built for this moment,
because this is the
moment that we came from.
Okay, so now, the most important question.
How can you use Khan Academy
to drive great remote
learning for your students?
So to make this really come alive,
I'm gonna use some of
those recommendations
that you just gave,
I'm gonna put them to use
live on the screen for your benefit.
So I'm going to split-screen mode here.
And what you see on the right hand side
is actually the live Khan Academy site,
the same way you see it if
you log in at khanacademy.org.
So the question that teachers often ask,
is how do I even get started?
How do I get my students enrolled?
So if you wanna do that,
all you have to do, is come over here.
And a lot of folks said hey,
I'm a high school math teacher.
So maybe you're teaching algebra,
and so you have your classroom.
And if you wanna add new students,
you have three different options
that I've categorized into
fastest, oldest and youngest.
And to explain what that means,
I'm gonna come over here
to the Admin section,
and then down to Students.
And under Students,
you're gonna see this
link to add new students.
And when you do that,
you get the exact same option
that you see there on the slide.
Do you want to use Google Classroom?
Do you want students to
join with the class link?
Or do you wanna actually
enroll your students yourself?
So the reason I say Google
Classroom is the fastest,
is that if you already have
a Google Classroom account,
all you have to do is connect that
and then import your students right away.
And you're all set and
they're there in Khan Academy.
So that is definitely the
fastest way to get started.
But if you don't have Google Classroom,
and you do have older students,
maybe middle school or high school,
you can absolutely have them
join themselves really quickly.
All you have to do is click that button,
students join with the class
link and you get a custom code
that you can put on your whiteboard,
on a screen, on an email,
where they can just join
and then you log into
your classroom right away.
And if you actually download the handout
that I've included here
in the GoToWebinar panel,
you can actually get a
special handout or slide
to give to your students
with that information.
What it has at the very end,
is your unique class code,
which identifies your
class from every other one
on Khan Academy.
And then finally, for your
very youngest students,
for the elementary teachers out there,
you can actually create
your students accounts
on your own, very quickly.
All you have to do is type in their names,
and then voila!
Khan Academy does two things for you,
number one is it
generates unique username.
And number two is
generates unique password.
And then if you create those accounts,
you can actually download
all that information
and then print it off for your students.
Give handouts for your students,
have them take it home,
and they're ready to go.
So those are the three
options to get started.
From fastest, all the way to
oldest and youngest students.
So that being said, as
a former teacher myself,
I can't resist that opportunity
to give you a little pop quiz.
So, quick question for everyone out there.
Where can you find your class code?
Is it located under Course mastery,
under Assignments, or under Settings?
Which of those three areas
on your Classroom dashboard
are gonna take you to your class code.
Thank you everyone for
weighing in very quickly here,
this is awesome.
We got almost 400 folks
around the country sharing their feedback.
And we'll go ahead and close this poll
and share the results.
And so you're absolutely right.
Settings is where you wanna go
and just to recap that,
you come back here to your classroom page,
you're skipping past Course
mastery, past Assignments,
and you come to the Admin section.
And you can find your class
code in your Students area,
right over here,
or in your Settings
field, right over here.
That's always where you're
gonna find your class code.
Okay, so next section.
Once your students are enrolled,
how do you get them prepared?
What we're gonna recommend is,
if you have the ability to
work with your students now,
before school closure events,
you're gonna have the best chance
to really get students
comfortable with the platform,
and familiar with the
routines associated with it.
So we highly recommend
that you start by assigning
a simple skill to practice.
So they understand the basic
mechanics of Khan Academy,
and they feel confident and in charge
when they use it at home.
That being said, we really recommend
that you add yourself to your own class,
so you can try it too.
'Cause is as important as
your student's practice.
We've seen time and again,
the most successful
educators with Khan Academy,
are the ones who feel
confident about it themselves
and who include themselves
in the experience.
So taking this class code for instance,
if you wanna add yourself to your class,
just to see what students are receiving,
the emails that are generated,
what an assignment looks like.
All you have to do, is
come up here to your name,
in the top right hand corner.
Go to your Learner home,
not your Teacher dashboard.
And then on this Learner page,
which is all about you as a
student, not as a teacher,
you're gonna come down
to this very bottom
section called Teachers.
All you have to do is
plug in your class code,
and you can join your very own class.
Now, you'll see everything
the same way that students do.
So you can know before
you make an assignment,
everything is the way that you want it,
and that's how you join your class.
Now, the other thing, is a
little bit less technical.
And that is,
not only should students be
familiar with Khan Academy,
but they should feel ready
for success in general.
And so I think there are a
couple things you can do today,
to really make sure they're
set up for success tomorrow.
Number one, do your students have
their login information handy?
If you download the handout
that I've attached here,
I have a simple worksheet
that you can print off
and hand out to your students
where they can write down the information,
including the login address,
so they have that or can even
share that with their parents.
That's the first step of course.
For your older students
who may have their own
smartphones or devices.
Let them know that they
can access Khan Academy,
not just through a computer,
but also through the Khan
Academy app on iOS or Android.
And if you have younger students,
maybe they don't even
have a computer at home
and you're worried about equity issues,
let them know they can
also access Khan Academy
on their parent's smart device,
even if they go to the mobile website,
or if they wanna download the app.
So another option to make sure
all of your students are served,
all of your students have access.
And then finally, Maeghan
really reiterated this to me
before this conversation tonight.
Which is, you wanna have a
lifeline to your students.
Meaghan was teaching in Connecticut,
during the time of Hurricane Sandy,
she made sure that she had a
clear line of communication
to her kids, using an LMS or an app like
ClassDojo or Remind or even just email.
And so make sure that you
have that set up in advance,
students know where to
receive information from you.
And then, also know that
Khan Academy will assist you
by sending notifications to your students.
So if they have the app or
if they have access to email,
they'll be notified that
they have an assignment
or Course mastery goal,
and that will keep them
moving towards the right goal.
Okay, that being said,
I wanna ask a little pop quiz to see
if everyone sort of caught
that important protip
about adding yourself to your class.
If you wanna add yourself to
your own class on Khan Academy,
do you do that by going
to your Student Roster,
or going to your Learner dashboard,
or by going to the Students
tab of your homepage?
Just to check for understanding here.
Old teacher habits die hard.
Thanks for everyone for voting
across the country so quickly.
I'll go ahead and close the poll,
share the results.
And voila!
You nailed it.
Again, you leave the sort of
cozy confines of your Teacher dashboard
and come over to Learner home
and there under the Teacher section,
you can add your class code
and join your own class.
That's exactly what your students see.
Okay, nicely done.
So just two final sections
and then we're gonna open
up for some live Q and A.
So, once you have your students enrolled,
once you have them set up for success,
how do you get the communication going?
How do you get assignments flowing?
Well, to set up assignments,
which is sort of a basic
functionality of Khan Academy,
all you have to do is come
back to your Teacher dashboard,
come into your class.
So again, so we're putting ourselves
in the shoes of high school
math teachers everywhere.
Maybe you're teaching algebra,
maybe you're teaching precalc,
and you come over here
to the Assignments tab.
Specifically, you click Assign,
and then you have your entire
curriculum laid out for you.
So maybe you chose a couple
of different courses,
pre-algebra, algebra one,
maybe even a little bit of early math.
In this case, let's go to algebra one,
and say, hey, right now
we're in the quadratic
section of the year.
Let's dig in there
and say I specifically want my students
to watch a polynomials video
and do an exercise on polynomials,
so the very introductory level.
And if you wanna check those out yourself,
all you have to do is click on them.
By clicking on the exercise,
you can instantly see the
total database of questions
that students will be faced with.
And once you've checked that
out and it feels good to you,
you can close that tab and
click the Assign button.
The nice thing about Assignments
is just like an assignment in class.
you choose the due date, the due time,
and you choose the specific students.
You can have all students
work on the same thing,
Or if you're ready to do
a little differentiation,
focus on the students who
really need a little bit
of remedial work and folks
who are ready to move ahead,
you can choose that as well.
And lastly, as you see here on the screen,
there is this protip,
which is, if you really
wanna make sure that
everyone has a different
experience, you can do that.
But there is an advantage
to giving the same
questions to all students,
which you're about to
see on the next slide.
Either way, you make your choice,
and you click the Assign button.
Now that assignment goes
out to the students,
they're notified and
they're off to the races.
So that's getting an assignment started.
But how do you review progress?
How do you sort of
close that feedback loop
with how the students are doing.
So if you come over to the Scores tab
right beneath Assign,
you can now see the
results that are coming in
from all these assignments.
At a student level, which is nice ,
to know that your students
are actually getting your assignments,
completing them, understand
how they're performing.
But you can actually dig
into the assignment itself,
and figure out how they
did, question by question,
across your student body.
And the reason I shared that protip
of having a shared set of questions
is that let's say, you're in a situation,
where you are able to
do a video conference
with your students for 30 minutes a day.
And you can share your screen
using something like
Zoom or Google Hangouts.
Well, what you can do
is you could actually go
through those questions
and point out, aha!
There's clearly a misunderstanding here,
we're seeing a pattern
where a lot of students
are missing the same thing.
Let me actually correct that
misunderstanding at the root.
Then you can actually draw
right on the screen if you want to,
and even give students hints,
give them a sense of how
they can sort of scaffold
all the way up to the right answer.
And that way,
even if you're not directly
connected with students,
you could have that
same level of feedback,
that same level of guidance,
that characterizes the
best teachers anywhere.
So that's how you get assignments going.
Now, one pop quiz for you here is,
do you have to assign the
same exercise to all students?
So think about this question for a second.
Is it mandatory to give
the same assignment
to every single student?
Or can you differentiate?
Can you spread it around?
I know this is an easy one,
we just talked about it,
just wanted to confirm this
'cause it's very important.
which is that, Khan
Academy is really focused
on letting teachers differentiate
and serve every learner where they are.
And so even though you may be tempted
to just sort of assign one assignment,
to every single student,
if you know that a student
needs something different,
feel free to use the Assignments tool
to pick and choose the students,
the same way you would
in your own classroom.
Okay, so that is the assignment piece.
And then finally, this
idea of mastery goals,
of course, it brings up the questions,
what exactly is a mastery goal?
Let me explain a mastery goal this way.
We've just talked about assignments,
which can often be very short-term.
Do this problem set tomorrow,
watch this video by tonight.
And that's great.
It gets you through the day,
especially when you're starting
with your remote learning cadence.
But if you know that you're
gonna be out of school
for two weeks, three weeks or more,
and you wanna set a longer term objective,
a mastery goal is about
setting the horizon
about where you want students to head
even if you're not gonna
be able to be with them
for a month or more at a time.
So that's the first
thing mastery goal does.
The second thing is, it lets
you set a really high bar.
As you just saw with assignments,
much of the focus is on,
get it done and get a score,
similar to worksheets.
But if you wanna say hey,
it's not just about getting
through the assignment,
it's about mastering the
core underlying skill.
That's where mastery goals come in.
Because they let you say,
hey, I don't want you moving forward,
and just sort of going through the motions
in these next two or three weeks,
I want you to always push yourself
to really understand and
master this new skill.
That's what a mastery goal can help with.
And so in terms of why you wanna use them
for remote learning,
number one, we all know that
one of the biggest sort of issues
with remote learning is that
students can feel disempowered.
Here I am behind the screen,
I'm not able to connect
with my teacher as directly,
here I am just going through the motions.
Whereas the mastery goal,
let's a student work as fast
or as slowly as they need to,
to ultimately master those key skills.
They're the driver of their destiny,
they have that level of empowerment.
And then number two,
when students do come back to school,
you don't wanna have wide gaps
because students were going really quickly
through your online assignments.
Instead, you wanna make sure you fill in
those foundational gaps.
And mastery goals really drive students
toward that level of
understanding before they move on.
So how do you assign mastery
goals in your classroom?
Well, to come back to our
Teacher dashboard here,
we're gonna go from Assignments
to the Course mastery tab, and
we're gonna click Placement.
what you can do here is
you can create a goal
for as few or as many
students as you want.
And these goals are typically
set at the course level.
So you might say, you know,
by the end of this year,
I want every one of my students
to have mastered all the
key skills of algebra one,
and I can assign that to
all of them or part of them.
And I can set the appropriate due date.
And that's the way that you get started.
But then, the magic of Khan
Academy's Course mastery goals,
come through actually
experiencing what students see.
So again, if you ever wanna see
what it looks like on the student side,
you come back to your Name menu
at the very top right hand corner,
you go to Learner home,
and then, you come over
here to Course mastery,
and you can see exactly
what the goal looks like
on the student side
and then you can see what it
looks like as they click in
and go through mastering their skills.
And again, when you
talk about empowerment,
so much of it is about understanding
what you've accomplished.
And this really gives
students a clear sense
of what have I mastered,
what do I still have left to work on.
And then finally,
is you wanna check that
progress yourself as a teacher.
You come back to your Teacher dashboard,
which you can always do just by clicking
the Khan Academy logo at
the very top of the screen.
You come into your desired class,
And then instead of
clicking the Placement tab,
you click the Progress tab.
Here, you can really dig
in the Course mastery,
at an entire course level,
as well as at a unit level.
So for example, if you
assigned a Course mastery goal,
where you want to understand
how students are doing with variables,
you could find out that aha!
We have some students who
have really mastered them,
which is awesome.
We have some students like Tori and Casey,
maybe needed a little bit extra practice.
And you can actually
click the Assign button
and assign that practice
just to the right student,
to give them a helping
hand even from afar,
to make sure they have everything
they need to be successful
and are constantly pushing
towards that high bar of mastery.
So that's how you check progress,
that's how you keep your
students moving forward.
So that being said,
I wanna finish up with one final pop quiz.
So as many folks out there will know,
Tim Vandenberg was one of
our Khan Academy ambassadors
and is a sixth grade math
teacher in Hesperia, California.
He did a really awesome
webinar for us last week.
We talked about the progress
that his students made
using Course mastery exclusively,
not even using assignments.
And so for anyone who was on that session,
I'm curious if you recall,
the incredible progress his students made,
in terms of the California
Math Assessment.
A high stakes test that
all of the students
had to take at the end of fifth grade?
We'll click these results,
we'll close the poll,
we'll share them with the audience.
And sure enough, you're absolutely right.
Tim had this astounding leap.
If you remember that graph,
which is kind of burned in my retinas,
which is, his students started sixth grade
60 points below grade level
and they ended up 34 points above.
Way more progress than the
state made or the district made,
or the county made on average.
And he attributed all to the fact that
focusing on mastery
and filling those gaps,
kept his students really
making sure they had
all the foundations they
needed to be successful.
So even in this difficult time,
I recommend checking it out
just to see what's possible,
as you try remote learning.
So that said, let me close
up with two final next steps,
and then we're gonna open
up some live questions.
So first of all, if you haven't already,
go to the Handout section,
and get my total cheat sheet
to this entire process.
Enrolling your students,
getting them ready for success,
making your first assignment,
setting your first Course mastery goals.
You can feel free to download that,
share that with educators down the hall,
share that with your administrators.
And then number two, if you
have any questions whatsoever,
please feel free to put
them into the questions box,
and Meaghan and I will answer those now.
So let's go ahead and start
with some good questions
that have been coming in,
and thank you everyone
who's been asking these.
So, let's start with
this important question
from Karen Leonard.
And I'm gonna bring this up to Meaghan,
because Meaghan is our
expert teacher trainer,
and she'll be able to respond directly
to this question Karen.
Karen wants to know, are there standards
connected to each activity Meaghan?
And if so, are they
national or state standards?
- That's a great question.
So for all of our math content,
and for our ELA content,
which we do have a small
section of ELA content in beta,
for those that might be looking for that.
It's all Common Core-aligned.
And from the teacher perspective,
if you go to make an assignment,
the same way Jeremy is
showing you on your screen,
all of the Common Core standards
will appear there for you.
The alternative is that if
you're looking for content
maybe to align to your
existing curriculum,
is that, in our Search feature,
you can search by topic
but you can also search by standard.
Some other things that might be helpful
if you're a science teacher,
we do have some NGSS-Aligned content
and if you're an AP teacher,
all of our AP courses are
aligned to the AP standards,
and you can search by those as well.
And if you're a high school teacher
interested in SAT preparation,
we do have official SAT practice.
And inside our SAT practice,
our content can be identified
by state-specific standards.
So only in the SAT part,
can you identify by
state-specific standards
otherwise is national
standards, mostly Common Core.
- Cool, great question, Karen.
Thanks for the great answer, Meaghan.
Okay, so next question here.
So just to see here,
Moses Lopez wants to know,
would you recommend Meaghan,
that teachers share an
account to work with students?
So let's say that you have,
you know, maybe students in
common with another teacher,
so do you have a single
account or separate account?
What's the best way to set that up?
- So if you have students that
are across multiple teachers,
I believe is what the
question is getting at,
is that your students
can have as many teachers
as they'd like.
And if they're making, if
you're using progress tracking,
as opposed to our individual assignments,
we're using progress tracking,
any teacher who has that
student on their roster
can see their progress.
So if for example,
you are, you know, third grade teacher
and you're using it for math,
but you might also have
support instructors
in your classroom, or additional,
you know, parents who
are in your classroom,
they can have an account as well.
They can track student
progress for students
and so that way teachers,
even though you can't share an account,
you're able to have access
to students progress.
- Cool.
Okay, this is a really important
question from Camden King,
this goes way beyond technology.
Any tips Meaghan,
on how to actually get
the kiddos to do the work?
Maybe using incentives beyond grades?
- Yeah, so what a great question (laughs).
For sure and so there's a couple of things
depending on the, you know, age group,
demographics of your students,
we find different success to this.
So Khan Academy also award
students Energy Points
while they're completing
assignments or doing work.
And those Energy Points
allow them to upgrade avatars
and earn badges and some sort of,
some of those internal kind
of gamification pieces,
we find to be really
motivating for students.
On top of that, we find
that teachers like to track
overall progress and provide
incentives around that.
Some of them can be as simple as,
we have printable certificates
on the site that show you,
oh, you mastered five skills
or you've really gone ahead,
or some teachers create their own,
you've completed all of first grade,
that's amazing and just recognize them.
That, whereas other teachers you know,
start to say if you make
x amount of progress,
we'll reward the class with,
you know, some sort of prizes,
which might be a little bit challenging
as we think about remote learning.
But I know that some
teachers will you know send,
again, digital recognition,
either in a certificate
or you know, some teachers
really go all the way
to Amazon gift cards,
I'm not encouraging that.
It's just something we've
seen in real classrooms
about ways to recognize student progress.
- Cool.
I've seen a couple questions here about
K through two or even preschool.
I do wanna to call out
- Yeah
- Khan Academy for kids,
which is our sister program.
It's all focused on ages two to six
and helping them really sort
of build the foundations
for number sense and for
reading and language arts.
And so if you're interested in that,
it's a free app that you can
download on iOS or Android.
So definitely check out the Khan Kids app,
as you can see right here.
Sort of going along with
that question, Meaghan,
Tina Lockman asks,
does Khan Academy have any reading lessons
or is this really just for maths?
- It's not just for math (mumbles)
I think that's a common
misconception is that,
we did start with math but
Khan Academy offers math,
science and engineering, computer science,
arts, humanities, economics.
We're partnered with College
Board as I mentioned,
and we have free as official SAT practice,
along with a fair amount of AP content
including things, AP
Computer Science Principles,
AP US History, AP Biology
is just getting revamped.
So there's plenty of content beyond math.
Our ELA content is just
in its early development,
and so if you are an English
Language Arts teacher,
and you're looking for some
content, we do have some.
And we would love to get
your feedback on that,
as well as we think about
developing that further.
And if you have early
learners, as Jeremy mentioned,
we do have the Khan Academy Kids app
which is focused on both early
literacy and early numeracy
along with social-emotional learning.
So if you have kiddos that are in that
two to seven age range,
we just published all first
grade content last week.
Very exciting for us.
So if you're looking for
that type of content,
I highly encourage you to look
at the Khan Academy Kids app,
which has a much more robust
language and reading component.
- Awesome.
Al Moreno ask a really
interesting question,
which is, obviously for a lot of students,
even if they don't have any
internet access themselves,
they might have it through
a parent's smartphone
or through the library.
But if there is just no
internet access available,
what would we recommend
in that case Meaghan?
- Yeah, it's a really tricky one.
And we do deal with this,
with some of the, you know, students,
we do work with school
districts all over the US,
which, obviously, you know, every school,
every district has their
own accessibility concerns.
And so one thing I will say is that,
everything as Jeremy
so kindly pointed out,
everything that's available
to students on the website
is available to them through the app.
And so even if they only
have access to a smartphone,
they can access the full content library,
all of their assignments from you.
All of that is still available,
And so we find that a
lot of students might
at least have access to a smartphone
for even a small part of their week.
And so that is one thing we
do see leveraged quite a bit.
If they have no access at all,
there is an option that if
you look at our Help Center,
"how do I help students who
have no internet access?"
We do have a partnership with organization
called Learning Equality.
And they have an option where
a student can download content
and access it offline.
However, they would still need a device,
in order to do that, to get the content.
We don't offer printouts
of all our exercises,
but as Jeremy is showing on the screen,
if you look in our Help Center,
and you find there, again, Kolibri,
which is part of Learning Equality,
they do offer an ability
to download Khan Academy
and other content.
They're not exclusively for us,
and so that students
can access that offline.
And we do see that use quite
a bit, mostly outside the US,
but inside the US and a
few locations as well.
- Fantastic and let's just
close with one final question,
which is, national certificates.
How would a teacher go about
getting access to those Meaghan?
As well as any other teacher resources
they we're developing?
- Great, great questions.
So once you log into Khan Academy
and you are logged into
your Teacher dashboard,
there's a place for you
and Jeremy I believe,
is gonna navigate to us right
there, called Resources,
that tab that Jeremy's hovering over.
And there you can see Getting
started with teacher training.
We have some teacher
training options there,
including a welcome guide and some videos
that show how teachers have
been using Khan Academy.
There's also some additional resources
when you go into that,
and you'll find resources for parents,
there's some Out-of-School
Program suggestions.
I know I used to work with
Boys and Girls Club of America quite a bit
and they would use some of
their after-school programs.
All of those types of things
like certificates and printables,
you can find them there.
If you're having trouble finding them,
always feel free to go to our Help Center.
And even if you do something
as simple as put certificates
into the search bar of our Help Center,
you'll just like that,
you'll be able to see them
and they do come in multiple languages
and those are printable
for your students, so.
- Great, okay, so let's
end it there Meaghan.
Thank you so much for
sharing your expertise
with our audience.
And thank you to our audience,
for taking the time out of your afternoon
or your evening to be with us.
I know there's so much going on right now.
We appreciate you
investing in this session.
That being said, do us one final favor,
please take the poll that pops up
at the very end of this webinar.
And let us know a, how can
we make future iterations
of the session even better?
And then b, what kinds of sessions
would you like to see going next?
Obviously, this is a
relatively high-level session
about getting started.
If you want us to dive
deep into math or ELA
or motivation or keeping students engaged
in a remote learning environment,
please just let us know.
We'll be sure to build it
out for our next session.
So on behalf of Meaghan and myself,
thank you so much for making
time to join us today.
We wish you tremendous success
as you get your students
set up for remote learning.
And if there's anything at all
we can do to be of service,
please just let us know.
Thank you again so much.
- Thank you very much.